un nuevo rumbo económico para argentina
el lunes la nueva ministra de economía
silvina batakis juramento en el cargo en
reemplazo a martin goodman quien
renunció el pasado sábado en medio de
las latentes tensiones entre el
mandatario alberto fernández y la
vicepresidenta cristina fernández
estamos convencidos de que el rumbo de
argentina tiene que ver con el manejo
fiscal de nuestras cuentas con seguir el
programa económico que el presidente
vino marcando
y lograr por supuesto que hay gente y
más exportaciones y revalorizar nuestra
moneda la economista tiene una larga
trayectoria en el sector público y es
más afín a la vicepresidenta y al ala
más radical de la coalición peronista
pero su llegada al ministerio enfrenta
grandes desafíos el lunes los mercados
financieros cayeron ante una
incertidumbre económica para que si se
tumbe siempre cuando cambio un ministro
es el doble más que nada de como el tema
del dólar y los mercados más que la
situación en sí económica porque esto no
se resuelve solamente con un ministro de
un día para el otro si bien batakis
forma parte del grupo más crítico con el
pacto entre el ejecutivo de fernández y
el fondo monetario internacional señaló
que dará continuidad al programa
económico del gobierno
esperamos trabajar con la ministra
silvina batakis y su equipo para
continuar apoyando a la argentina y a su
gente a fortalecer la estabilidad
macroeconómica y abordar sus profundos
desafíos para sentar las bases de un
crecimiento más sostenible e inclusivo
la nueva ministra tendrá que enfrentar
además una inflación superior al 70 por
ciento anual un elevado déficit fiscal
así como mantener vivo el diálogo con el
fmi